[Music]
my name is beer
welcome back to them we're gonna solve
this mystery
right here right now we have all the
balls oh we need to go to the ball I
have but you have all the balls and we
go to the ball I have my balls for
gutter ball
hey how about it balls will go to the
ball alright time to solve puzzles don't
even think about it
don't even think about it ah no puzzle
you think that this little things
causing us so much trouble I just want
to kick it to outer space I suppose all
we can do now is to send the signal and
help well ready did I miss something
I don't remember this I'm really
confused right now
what it no they can't come back
something's happening quick send it
again
what's going up turn red dr. Thomas
wrong
what take over for me Lily his
conditions has been destabilized intake
levels must still be complete
now I have no idea what's going on but
what's happening to this is he dying
it's been this stabilized get out what
get out of this memory now what are you
talking about if the system doesn't
stabilize soon this shock might
permanently damage whoever's in there
you gotta be kidding me
why aren't you getting out that I can't
Neal if both of us get out on this date
all that work will be reset there won't
be any enough time to redo what all
we've done before Johnny are you
freaking don't pull that country crap on
me
this ain't a movie and you're no hero
you just being a Maura what is he
through the arts well then why are you
being one to get the hell out of you
screw that
if you're gone they'll probably pair me
up with a Lulu star
that girl is an idiot do you know how
badly oh he smells worse than the
roadkill damn it Neal this is what I get
for helping you cheat through the
entrance exam I knew it
what did what in the hell what in heaven
it's been stabilized good doctor or
maybe not what happened did you die I
think we're all yes we made it brother
don't even worry about it I thought I
was gonna die there for a second but
with these skills that were deer skills
and guess what your carrot cake sucks
that's a good good disc right there I
mean if someone would say that my carrot
cake sucks I don't know where I would be
made a minute yeah and at the last
Christmas party you what
oh wait survived come on let's go before
that happens again
um you know what I didn't mean to you
know Kalia Amara you know that I did
right huh all right are we going to the
ball here goes nothing
all right that was a good way to create
tension for her no specific reason but
hey maybe we'll see something in the
future why are we going anyway if you
haven't followed up Jonny had some like
it took some medicine that would make
his memories we disappear or something
like that
he wants to suppress them wow I can't
believe that work so we actually made it
and he didn't really have to take the
medicine so there's something you
obviously want to hide but now I'm not
sure if I'm going to like this place
what do you mean it's same speech for me
now
Neal did you notice some guarding on
Johnny's room earlier all right what
there was something strange in there did
you not see it the Platypus I I suppose
not I didn't see it did you brush see it
never mind
I just hope I'm wrong what the hell are
you girl
Wow that sounds fabulous I know right
you got to take them for one day
fabulous fabulous girl
[Music]
what's going on that is oh yeah why
didn't he talk sheesh
the time overlaps getting out of hand
look I'm Maddie out of him there are
it's like a suit can we investigate him
[Music]
come on dude fine
what is this doing here all thanks to
this little fellas sacrifice I am
did you realize something there or what
a week I'll be collecting but look at me
is dying this is not no bueno
[Music]
but what in the hell oh yes
oh jeez look at the time I'd better get
going it's still closes early tonight
ah take care Martha say hello to the
boy's father I will I'll see you around
which boys which boys don't guess -
buzzer Spanish his flawless well this is
the end of the road and you were saying
never mind
maybe I was wrong after all you missed
the valley below girl I mean this place
is so peaceful the only thing that
exists in this memory that could do such
a thing would be it gets all run over by
a car [ __ ] duh oh my god we need to go
back now I don't know what wait what's
going on now just shut up a cop oh my
god what's going on she's gonna run over
him done no no no no little Timmy no no
now that it's not - it's his brother
oh my god no
no don't dead you have to look in the
rear
[Music]
stupid girl have to look at them for you
know no much say that you only met I
don't understand if he was unconscious
how could he be seeing this here when he
never did
Wow still I'm just surprised oh it was
him I was wrong
sorry actually he did it I was right all
right what did it didn't see it in his
room nail Johnny slept on a bunk bed
Joey no no Joey can you hear me Joey why
did you hit Joey mom why did you hit him
Joey
wake up Joey wake up I'm so sad why did
you do it mommy no no II
even though they were young who is a
twin brother not to mention how their
first must feel mother must feel at
least Johnny had the beta-blockers erase
the memories not like I remember as much
[Music]
possibly unlinked not erased somewhere
in there the aftermath of those memories
probably lingered
what about their mother I don't think
she took the beta-blockers she seemed to
have gone a little cuckoo at least I
don't really think she called Johnny
Joey as a nickname I think if she then
takes Johnny for Joey what about Johnny
himself it's true I don't like it here
that's mama it seems like this wasn't
the only memory unlinked ah it's not
putting up a barrier anymore don't jinx
it
that is so saying poor Johnny
oh so now they are twins yes we
successfully went back in time do should
totally give this series a trial
I mean really it's just wicked awesome
I already clone through three books Trey
why does it car anymore oh that's a gap
that's about this group of kids turning
into animals to fight mind controlling
slugs man I'm I don't like that weird
alien stuff
why not it's great instead of going to
boring school they get to turn into
tigers and mauled big bad aliens they're
all like rah rah rah rah rah rah rah
sorry I got to enjoy and then they pick
up lace oh my god and it's all like
sorry again
stop hey that's the best explanation of
a story ever
just watch Donnie one day I'm gonna be a
famous riding I'll write the coolest
novel on the block and every kid will
get my book for free I'll make us rich
how will you make them rich if the book
is odd and buy both for Yuma and big
houses how would you get rich if you
give away the babies exactly free for
the kids the path still had to pay of
course yeah I'm sure the parents the
three to give you money what you're
still mad about the other day what
happened there all right come on I
called first dibs on the Train fair and
square
what happened to your prize anyway I
gave it away to a hobo look it's not
just about that day it's about
everything Joey you know Mauro is
favored you hey that's not true
remember last Christmas and lassies sir
and the time we went fishing
that's so sight you shouldn't favor eyes
kids parents okay okay you know what
you can have my train if you want really
yeah I mean hey by your reasoning she'll
just get me another one right listen
Johnny what difference does it make who
owns what everything that's mine is
yours tip that it's all sweet I mean we
both get to play with it right
Yeah right I mean come on you know much
my brother dude you're like a part of me
[Music]
alright let's come yes let's go confuse
the name wait in the rain yes and the
rain come on oh that's out of sight
whoa holy [ __ ] all right breast it's
time to go back in time but guess what
and then next episode so like a pyramid
if you enjoy it's gotta come with red
today and I'll see you next episode
every week some of the wagons are dying
into sleep a heart attack I think I
shouldn't leave a padlock I know where
that padlock is nice it's gelding by
singing the padlocks on a low padlock
girl I want to rock your world
where'd my padlock [ __ ] girl come on
girl let's rock my